okay
good morning everybody good morning
everyone welcome to our plans committee
meeting of the 14th of april
welcome to any maybe watching on
george's youtube site
um first thing i'll get the committee to
introduce themselves
and if they speak up so everybody else
can hear because i'm lucky i've got a
microphone
but i'm chris leather i'm a counselor
from northern border
and i'll start with
council watson and my world is broady
captain rose and i represent two rivers
and three laws
morning my name is peter christie and i
represent biddeford north
good morning i'm richard i represent
today for parker brown
good morning my name is donald goff and
i represent a bit of the north
and then i'll get the officers present
to introduce themselves starting on my
left good morning members one of the
members of public my name is sean
harrington and i'm the planning manager
at clark district council
good morning my name is stacy dory i'm
head of legal government district
council
morning my name is christy lee i'm um
lovely thank you
we're not expecting any fire drill this
morning
um and we certainly hope there's no
reason
so if anybody if we've got to leave
please leave by the way that you came in
up the stairs here
but don't lose the left please
right okay i agent one the agenda is
apologize for absence
one apology councillor brown councillor
thank you
item two on the agenda is the minutes of
the
west plans committee meeting
held on the 10th of march on pages 5 to
14
in our results from the chair
one second thank you council knox
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
item three on the agenda is declarations
of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interests
when the item has been considered
elected members of devon county council
and turner parish councils who've
considered an applicant a planning
application
by virtue of their membership of that
council called a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
and i always have that it's at this
plans committee meeting we have
all the latest information which isn't
always necessarily available
to town and parish councils
okay item four is agreement on the
agenda between parts one and two and
there is no part two
item five urgent matters
six is public
participation this is where i advise the
committee
of any prior request to speak made by
members of the public and to advise the
details of the council's public
participation scheme
well for the
applications this morning
we've got 15 contributors down
for the applications
and the orders for speakers
is that the planning officer will give
their presentation of the application
and then any terrain or parish council
representative who wishes to speak
for or against the application has three
minutes
up to two public speakers are permitted
who wish to speak against the
application and they again have three
minutes to address the committee
and then up to two public speakers in
support of an application and they also
have three minutes each
but then any tourist council member for
the award in which the application falls
they have no time limit but we do like
it is they stick to about three minutes
as well
and then after that is when the plans
committee will then debate the
application
okay item 7 on the agenda is is planning
applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained
in the reports are correct at the date
of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
[Music]
due to these term constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
and we start with our first application
at 7a
which is on pages
15 to 53 of your agenda
the planning um
christian evelyn chrissy will present
nationals thank you
thank you
sir
council christie
there's a
this application is for the installation
and operation so far to go with all
associated works equipment and
infrastructure
that is that web repairs and cheap farm
and it says this
um
if you go to the next slide
uh following updates um are since the
publication of my report
so um the british and initial security
strategy has been published and the
contents that do not change my
recommendation
and uh trying voices that will remain
development
there's been additional radiocarbon
dating information received um
vcc biology requires
uh required
again it doesn't impact
sorry chris can you speak into the
microphone yeah sorry
um
one additional representation um has
been received um contents of it um
there's no additional points raised
above those which are already summarized
in the report
is that for or against because very
unusual we've got more letters
in support this time um is it for or
against that last one sorry it was an
objection right
i'm going to hold the marker thing
because i can't tilt my head and look at
the screen and
yeah
so you can see uh this is now a photo of
the site
in the top left hand corner you can see
the house goes to philly food
and the site is actually the pink hatch
area in the central area um to the south
uh
you've got poncho across
the south east corner
[Music]
and to the south uh west you can see
richardson
uh scarborough um
[Music]
this is a site showing uh
location plan with field numbers since
12 years in total
with the existing substation and um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to the site going out of the price
direction
and
the one views so
this is the existing national grid
entrance
southeast
you can see the uh there's a
handy start location included on this so
you can see where the photos take
performance
so this is looking at
construction entrance would be
um
so there's no cameras in that field it
will be used for construction actions
and then in the distance
and start please
this is the southern entrance of the
site and smart display to be used for um
construction etc
[Music]
this is from uh southwest uh south
county law cross
is looking out to share the topography
reservations
[Music]
thank you very much so uh this is from
hancock um it's looking up this is one
of the more areas um
so far
you can see the science western parts of
detail um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
societies but more with the eastern
parts of the sun
due to the topography
and as you would know the markets report
it's the western part of the sun which
is more prominent
from southern more patients and much of
these
as well as the visually impact devices
[Music]
inside so here we have uh again before
and after so if we go practice supports
five times
and that's right yeah that's
you know
if you zoom
[Music]
[Music]
you can't really see very much from this
futures uh
existing screen
next like please
so this is from dell's grave cross which
uh probably no one knows about that is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is from our desktop um it's just
off the main road now as well as a
bigger gateway um
[Music]
south west
you can see the science western parcel
there
then we have some before and afters
which are probably most useful so if we
um
but if we zoom in you can just you can
see the existing substations
[Music]
and you can see that they are planned
and halfway up that there's a house on
the top so that field would then be
about halfway out there
[Music]
and then um
see the existing
[Music]
this is looking from the north of the
site and as detailed in my office report
as we've seen on the
officer side
the site is mainly visible from the
south and it's not very visible from the
east side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
much more distance
again it's 12 screens
from woodland
really was popular
as well
so
in the north
this shows the landscape features plan
so you can see um
i'm sorry if it was qualifying but um
you can see the sign
in red and there's other red lines on
there which
headlines
um
[Music]
there's
existing roads overhead lines etc so
it's mainly to show that
existing development on the site as well
as the existing substation
next slide please
this is uh the bow and landscaping plan
and because the site is quite big it's
um
it's probably not showing you too much
about coming in and going through it but
uh i'm still sure there's existing
petrol has been retained
[Music]
infrastructure
[Music]
distance etc
[Music]
[Music]
this is a spare part storage container
keys
an auxiliary transformer
[Music]
another
a
transformer
substation
defense with uh
some should be gained from now
okay
[Music]
is some onto
the landscape of the area as you might
expect from a 63 hectare so far
there's some
lessons to come out to
setting off some of the buildings
however in my opinion
the benefits of the scheme
[Music]
weigh those negatives and previously
recommended
and i'm just going to pass back to the
chair while i put a mic on that table
and she's generally interested in this
thank you very much
thank you chris thank you for your
[Music]
thank you presentation our first speaker
to the app this application is mr dale
hall
from the cpre devon
against the application
[Music]
we're told that applications like this
are are virtuous
we know we're living in times of crisis
a food crisis
energy crisis ecological crisis
cost of living crisis and a climate
crisis
so
how will this proposal help those kinds
of crises
it won't help the food crisis by taking
farmland out of food production but in
devon that produces the finest meat and
dairy products
food miles will be increased and the
idea that sheep or any other stock will
graze under the panels
is untrue and unnonsense
so it won't help the food crisis
nor will the proposal produce
electricity when we most need it in
winter when it's cold and dark
instead it will produce most electricity
in the middle of the day in summer when
we already have surplus electricity
on average we only produce electricity
for about 10 percent of the time when we
all use electricity 100 percent of the
time
so it won't help the energy crisis
it won't solve the ecological and carbon
crisis either
the proposal would remove farmland which
if sustainably and regeneratively farmed
stores huge amounts of carbon in the
soil
the installation was in fact a massive
carbon footprint because of the huge
amount of diesel and coal
used to mine refine
manufacture transport and install the 75
000 solar panels and other equipment
it won't reduce emissions by displacing
emissions from other power stations
because by 2030 95 percent of the
electricity will be decarbonized
so it will never pay back its own large
carbon footprint
because of the necessary maintenance
that's to say cleaning the solar panels
managing the grass and scrub using big
machines and herbicides
more fossil fuel will be
used and the soil will be severely
degraded
and no longer a carbon sink so it won't
solve or help to solve the climate
crisis
in reality the development would drive
up the price of both food and
electricity the large capital outlook
the cost of maintenance the cost of
decommissioning
will all have to be paid for by the
consumer through higher electricity
prices for unwanted and unneeded
electricity so it won't solve the cost
of living crisis
to summarize the proposed solar farm
won't help solve any of the five crisis
rather it would make them worse the
planning application should be refused
on the basis of the proposal would
provide no benefits to offset the harm
to the landscape for the wildlife and to
food production
we should all be concerned because the
natural environment in devon is under
threat from development such as these
and they're not as virtuous as they
purport to be
thank you thank you thank you mr board
[Music]
and our next speaker against the
application is keith baxter
thank you for having me
if you'd like to speak right into the
end of that perform please
[Music]
that's fine that's fine can you hear me
okay yeah
and once you settle in a few three
minutes as well
yeah i will go for it um
i'm a near neighbor and i've never
before in my life objected to any
planning development
and i didn't object to the existing 28
micellar power plants which sits
adjacent
to alba discot substation near gamiton
mall
the current solar installation built by
light source in 2013 occupies a
relatively modest acreage in this set in
the valley
if approved this new 137 acre
development
would be totally out of scale
within its bucolic rural environment
the cleave farm element traverses up
hill almost to the summit of the 150
meter os marcus stone
it would occupy high ground and would
stick out like a sore thumb
the government's latest energy strategy
which was mentioned earlier
has shifted focus accelerating the
deployment of wind new nuclear and
hydrogen
the government is consulting on the
rules for solar projects particularly on
domestic and commercial rooftops
which is where in my view solar panels
should be installed
not on our rolling green fields
i believe the countryside should remain
countryside and not be blighted by
industrial development
and do not be fooled by light sources pr
buff
these solar power stations are not farms
the dictionary definition of farm
is an area of land
together with a house and buildings used
for growing crops
and or keeping animals as a business
there is no clear farm with the house
and buildings here
it's just pastureland
this part of north devon is not
classified as an area of outstanding
natural beauty but if you could drink in
the views across the grasslands the
north and east of our property
you would instinctively know
that it is an area of natural beauty
i googled solar farms in devon
and saw an advert at the top of the
search results stating
lease your land for up to a thousand
pounds an acre starting from 50 acres no
costs and no risk for you
this kind of tempting advertising is
deeply saddening because some farmers
will choose to make an easy buck
farmers are the tenants and custodians
of our countryside and they should be
preserving and reinstating lost habitats
for the benefit of future generations
this proposed development would destroy
the area's biodiversity
and light source cannot be trusted to
fulfill their promise to implement the
planting plan
take a look at google earth and you'll
see that their form atlantic plan
promised that part of as part of the
existing solar development failed to
materialize
as well as agriculture much of the
economy of devon is based on tourism and
i actually can wind up please yeah i am
winding up i've got one more paragraph
to go turrish district council states
torridge a great place to live work and
visit on its letterhead visitors come
here because of the landscapes coastal
and england beauty i believe each solar
development has a detrimental impact on
our landscape's visuals
i therefore passionately urge torres
district council to totally reject this
industrial developments and wait for
clarity on the government's new energy
strategy
which will hopefully hold all
future greenfield solar developments
[Music]
our next speaker is
david moore in support of the
application
all right good morning everybody do you
mind if i stand up
as long as you start if i understand
that i do sitting because i've got two
false hips which i've had for the last
20 years
and i must say how successful they are
well i would just like to say that my
wife and i purchased clean farm wage
effort in 1968
and higher
and we have been both continued farming
successfully
till now
at the beginning of 2010 our family
farming partnership started to look
at other income streams because farming
incomes had been dropping renewable
energy was the obvious answer
to our thoughts
we found solar energy to be the answer
for the following reasons
our number one our sheep
could continue grazing and enjoying the
comfort from the shaded panels
the land chosen was not suitable for
arable cropping
only summer grazing
number two
the land in question is next door to a
high voltage substation probably one of
the largest substations in the southwest
which is attached to a line from taunton
to indian queens
however the expected output from this
original site was not great enough
to plug into this equipment
three
at the top at that time
we made contact with various businesses
to install a solar panel system
light source
were chosen to be preferred company
because of their expertise in the field
the panels were installed in 2013
and have operated successfully to date
with the sheep raising beneath the
panels
and all very happily and i'm quite happy
to take any of you there to have a look
having had no regrets with our preferred
company we again approached them to
extend the solar system to a larger
array
with the added benefit for the generated
power to be connected directly into the
neighboring high voltage transformer
station
i would like to emphasize that this
proposed planning application serves our
country well
we can continue producing food for our
nation
we shall be
reducing our cattle numbers
and increasing the sheep
therefore reducing the risk of the risk
of pollution to our fabulous
torres valley
this
should this application should be if
this application should be successful
it will be a win-win
situation
for us all
thank you for listening to me this
morning we believe it is most important
under present circumstances with the
world in disarray
self-sufficiency by looking after
ourselves is the order of the day
thank you very much thank you mr moore
our next and final speaker to this
application francis mann
um in support of it and you're the
applicant indeed
good morning everyone chair members
thank you very much the opportunity to
speak today in support of this important
opportunity to help tackle the climate
crisis
it's a special honor it's my house and
uncle farmer by winkley where i've come
from this morning and i've been covering
them since i was in the womb
lifesource vp is both a national and
international leader in the funding
development and long-term management of
large-scale solar projects with many
years of industry experience including a
clean
this application for a solar farm will
help to significantly tackle the issues
of energy security and climate change
through increasing renewable energy
generation whilst reducing carbon
emissions
over 10 000 tons of carbon will be saved
annually by this project the equivalent
of taking over 5 000 large family cars
off the road
this will help touristic council to
achieve the ambition set out in the
carbon environmental biodiversity plan
the application will also meet national
commitments and obligations to net zero
including those set out by the
government in its necessary strategy as
well as the recently published energy
security strategy
the generation of solar power is one of
many initiatives that will play an
important role in meeting the
government's 2035 target where
electricity come from low carbon sources
if approved in addition to generation of
home grown and secure renewable energy
the proposed installation will provide
several other benefits including
1065 meters of additional hedgerow
planting to enhance the natural
screening of the soda farm and support
local wildlife
other biodiversity enhancements
including bird and black boxes and areas
in one of our meadow
which will result in a biodiversity net
gain of 55 which is significant
this proposal will also support as we've
heard from david just now the long-term
capability of the ford family farmer
weber barton and the moors are clean and
they continue our cultural operations
through the continued lifestyle grazing
of sheep and this uh progressive and
others will visit the site and test
either our sheep on the cliff currently
and there will be in the future
lastly there will be economic benefits
including a contribution of
approximately 125 000 pounds a year per
annum
a year in business rates to torres
district council
light source bp has carried out
extensive pre-application community
engagement with local residents and
other key stakeholders and the majority
of written feedback was positive
since submission we have engaged
officers and submitted further details
to address queries raised and note that
none of the statute consultees have
raised an objection
this is an application that accords with
your local plan and with current and
emerging government policy on how to
achieve that zero
your local plan policy st-16 confirms
support for renewables and low carbon
energy subject to meeting the detailed
criteria which this application does
safe
secure
and low impact energy supply has never
been more of a necessity
as it is today in the face of climate
change and geopolitical events that we
are all watching in moral televisions
this is pushing supplies to the brain
last week the u.n reiterated the message
that is truly now or never to actual
climate change stressing the global
emissions of co2 would need to peak for
2045 so let's ready to act as you're
aware your officers have recommended
approval after carefully weighing up all
the planning considerations accordingly
with the needs act on climate change and
security now i've respectfully asked
your members to grant planning
permission in accordance with your
officer's recommendation thank you very
much
thank you very much
right that's the end of our speakers and
council lock you can start with all
rules
yeah i'd just like to say this is in my
wallet and i was asked by three
residents to call the application in so
that's why it was called in
um
just a few general points i was really
disappointed that the parish councils of
albania and huntsville and yarnstein
have made no response to the application
but i can understand about averages
getting punctual but i note that benefit
town council recommended approval and
also
have no adverse comments to make
um it's already been mentioned by
character christie that there are more
support letters and objections
and i'm listening intently to the cpre
gentleman this morning because i was
going to mention that all four objection
letters from cpre were not signed by
anyone so i was pleased i can now put
they named cprv comments
um comments have been made to the
objections about the lack of public
consultation i attended a virtual public
consultation event held on zoom back in
october 2020
for which i know 161 nearby residents
were involved i cannot unfortunately
remember how many people were present
um
just i'll leave it there see what my
other fellow committee members say but
then i've got some more comments to make
but that is just the background to why i
called it
thank you council lock
nobody understand
councilman craig
[Music]
make sure
um
whether that's true or not
we have to look at this application
sometimes now
there is a condition uh which does
actually require the monitoring of their
advancing and biodiversity scheme um
so i would be very satisfied that that
condition is uh it covers all the points
and we
thank you councillor christie
thank you yeah um
again to the
uh speakers um they were very
interesting
um i must admit i wasn't convinced by
the cpre because some of their points
i find really odd
actually um
having said that you'll notice that uh
as councillor locke has already pointed
out the biddeford town council
uh we voted unanimously in favor of this
i'm the chairman of the town council
planning middle
and because of that we went through it
and very you know we got a little great
detail we've heard today and i will
propose that we accept this
all right thank you council christie
our second
after
[Music]
i've written it down because i
that counts a lot and like the rest of
you
i'm sure went through
all the responses on the website
i actually said the cpre report from the
31st of october was a very good report
it went into some some issues that
weren't strict declining
reasons
about slave labor where these things are
made abroad not the rest of it and
but getting on to on for 160 acres
an agricultural land with woodland and
hedgerows brimming with all manner of
flora and fauna the impact on landscape
character which is on page 38
of your report there
that three points
at 3.19
speaks about this in this case both
landscape character types
are likely to be highly sensitive to
development of this scale
and in our delivering renewable energy
and heat policy st 16
proposals for development incorporating
on-site provision of renewable energy
other than wind energy
or renewable heat and or low carbon
technologies will be supported and
encouraged where appropriate and at a it
does talk about landscape sensitivity
is best then to accommodate them
assessed in accordance with the cancer
landscape sensitivity
assessment and the landscape sensitivity
to accommodate the scale and development
so
there is a conflict here and
quite properly um our planning officer
has drawn attention to the conflicts
another one
others are on page 42 at 3.61
where
let's get to that
west the planning offices states that
overall there is some policy conflict
which arises from this scheme
and
if you've read i'm sure you have read
through the report you'll see where
these
conflicts arise now we all know that our
policies
are down for interpretation depending on
the application that they're being
applied to you can interpret them
various ways and then ppf itself
is open to interpretation in some
instances
and an application like this is very
subjective too
we all know we can't
um
make an applicant
explain the need for renewable energy we
all accept the need for renewable energy
but it does come down to where that is
located
and how it's to be constructed
and i'll i'll carry on with a bit
down to the either
for me the application provides no
evidence and for me this is important of
any benefits for local residents or
details of the energy generated long
term
taking into account the reduction in the
effectiveness of
solar panels over time i can't see
where there's any increase in the
enhancement of biodiversity
there is a length of
new hedge
headline to be put in
only reduction in the name though
of electrical generation as it has been
said by one of the speakers is at midday
in the summer months
and then he commentates on solar energy
put the output at no more than ten
percent
of that claim per annum there's been no
carbon assessment
so the potential crt emission of savings
we've heard a figure of over ten
thousand dollars mentioned there was no
evidence presented in the application
for that
so the savings are completely unknown
the draft national policy statement for
renewable infrastructure
bracket cm3 includes solar pv
overarching national policy statement
for energy
bracket cn1 all proposals for energy
infrastructure
projects should include a target
assessment as part of their
environmental statement we haven't got
that here and really ought to be
supplying this information
it's and again i said a minute ago it is
undeniable there will be some planning
policy conflicts on this application
so
to finish really are we really content
that the damage
to the landscape and wildlife is worth
it
for the intermittent generation of
electricity with no proof of any carbon
reduction
thank you cancel it out
and i'd like to come back on one or two
of those i was like that i am the
farmers well and so i do know um about
the loss of land and the graves of
various land
um just a few comments highways have got
no objections because the proposed route
has been used previously
natural england
state that there's no significant impact
identified and therefore they do not
object
with regards to the wildlife and habitat
i think i've mentioned before that i
know of a local farmer with solar panels
on his land and he sees a lot more
nesting birds as they go under the
panels for shelter eg runs he sees a lot
more pheasants and partridge and more
hedgehogs and hairs
and he
the emoji rise between the panels twice
a year which in turn attracts a lot more
insects such as ladybirds
um with regard to
in the environmental damage the
conservation officer our own
conservation officer
accepts the findings of the heritage
statement carried out what peppa says
and says the visual impact on views
looking back to hunt shaw will be less
than substantial
so i would also recommend approval
thank you mm-hmm
anybody else before go and move jeffree
councilman
yeah thank you very much i'd just like
also i am in support of council
christie's
of the application of grant that reason
being this committee has tried for many
years now trying to stipulate his
developers obviously to
ascertain solar panels on their new
dwellings going up we all know
unfortunate fundamentals of that known
for this so my reason supports
application is
we've got to be forward thinking
some people are not going to like it but
for the wider good i think this
application should go through
because we do need the renewable energy
and to be honest if the atlanta
greyhound did come off this substation
is actually primed
for that to come through and for me
that's my main reason sporting this
application i think the office has done
a great report the details going in for
the pictures and i do know land very
well
and with the visual aspect of it going
in i think the visual aspect you know it
doesn't really harm the area that much
to be honest
like anything you're going to see any
development going through whether it's a
single wedding going through all ten
thousands to go through you're gonna see
it
if you don't like it you're gonna see it
it's gonna become you know binge your
life but
going forwards for the residents etc you
know we need solar energy we need
renewable energy and we're gonna
we don't start now we're never gonna
start exactly so i'm in full support
thank you councilman
nobody else wants to make comment and
right it's been removed by council
christie
sent me by councillor watson to approve
this application
could you take the vote please
yes thank you chair council about him
for chancellor bushby or councillor
christie or cancer craigie or pencil
leather
thank you sandra
when we move on into our next
application
if chris has got his breath annex
application
7d which is on pages 54 to 67
of your agenda
thank you
thank you
um i'll just wait a minute
[Music]
oh i'll get started um this application
relates to the changing plan to increase
the maximum number of pitches um from 5
to 15 at a stiffer parameter site
[Music]
[Music]
uh
chris
chris could you use
is it next like this
uh so this is just showing where the
list of buildings are something uh
this site as well so they're actually
blue you can see there's a list of
building
crossroads to the north and there's also
a radar side there
within
the borrowers itself
this is the site location plan it shows
that out so there'll be
heart standing pitches and um
programs planting and super location
with the existing store and access their
next slide please
this is from the entrance system with
visibility
so this is looking
[Music]
for as i may sound
um
just pop back one side please yeah
yeah this is looking sound so
next slide
this is
[Music]
the container
is placed into it
inside these
this is the site um it's quite long and
narrow it's um on both sides by petrol
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um if you zoom in you can
see a caravan there so that's not
actually a parallel site um behind that
there's a hedgerow and then there's a
caravan side and then
you see the
two dwellings there on the left-hand
side of the ones
uh
the containers there there's 12 houses
in the background
[Music]
obviously
[Music]
on the side when this is taken and if
you zoom in you just start seeing it
move structures
and slide please
so this just shows the site and
screening
inside
you can start having system houses you
can see the proximity
there
inside these
these are the main plan considerations
and you see that approval subject to a
variety of conditions including
seasonal use of crowds and only touring
caravans
to limit their overall safety back to
the scheme
i'll now pass back to china to institute
students thank you
thank you chris
right we've got
three speakers to this application
and the first the first speaker again
[Music]
the other one which is that's the one
thank you very much
right when you settle you've got three
minutes to remove the counselor my name
is
and i live at the croft which is on that
plan
the site is outside of any development
boundary is a very narrow site so close
to residential properties of which mine
the craft sits in the center
there are a number of points which give
me great concern
out of the many applications submitted
for this site only two have ever been
approved the curse for a move for moving
the entrance with a single-gated bill
and the second for an iso steel
container as a cl store
clad in timber effect cladding neither
have been carried out as per the
application
therefore why should this application be
carried out or managed as submitted when
the previous two applications have
knocked
so looking at this application together
with a drawing of seabreeze caravan site
which is on screen
and attached to the application the
three pitches on the eastern boundary at
the northern end of the site show on
plan as existing green pitches with
electric hookups and water standpoint
the plan shows it to be at a scale of 1
to 1 250 which is accurate with the
dimensions of my bungalow and land
the plan shows three pitches to be
within 20 meters from the northern
boundary with the electric hookups and
water standpipe within that 20 meters it
shows existing but at present the three
pitches are 5 meters 30 meters and 50
meters from that boundary the electric
hookups are 5 meters and 25 meters from
that boundary and the water standpipe is
45 meters from that boundary not as
shown
so if as stated consideration be given
to neighboring properties why has this
not been implemented and put into
practice and consideration shown now
living next door to this site we are
subjected to dogs barking sometimes
three per van
the smells from the barbecues the noise
of music and the external caravan lights
which are some are left on all through
the night which have necessitated us
installing blackout curtains to our
bedroom
increase this to 15 pitches which is
three times the present number then all
of these things will increase whether
one likes it or not and whether the site
is seasonal or all year round
to me there is not much that satisfies
policy dm 01 as the planning officer has
suggested
to adversely affect the impact on the
undeveloped coastal area and the area of
outstanding natural beauty and therefore
spoil the very things tourists wish to
come to visit
would to me have a negative effect on
tourism i like to encourage tourism to
the area it is the bread and butter of
our locality
but
it's just that unfortunately
this site is just in the wrong place
so councillors
i say to you if this were being put at
the side of your property and you would
be affected as i am that people look
into your conservatory and to see the
beans on the toast that you're eating
would you
be able to justify and accept it i thank
you for your time thank you mr harmon
thank you
the next speaker
against the application is serene
three minutes as well to address the
commissions it feels a bit like
mastermind
good morning everyone my name is sarah
mendoza i am chair of the ecuador
residence association
um i'm reading something which actually
keith goodwin
prepared but was unable to come this
morning
um so while this application reduces the
number of caravans applied for
on the site from 30
in a previous application
to 15
nevertheless i suggest the same argument
should apply in repeating a decision to
refuse
the site is in the undeveloped coast
and should be subject to the governing
policies st 21 and st 09 regarding the
spatial vision and strategy
for north devon and northern
respectively
it should not be emphasized that under
st 09 in bracket 7 the proposed
development should be judged not by
impact on landscape character as implied
by the applicants
but by the following four tests that is
whether it would detract from the
unspoiled character
appearance and tranquility of the
undeveloped coast and whether
development could go elsewhere outside
the undeveloped coast
i submit that the number of
caravans applied for would fail these
tests
the character of the site and
surrounding countryside its appearance
and tranquility would be adversely
impacted visually by the presence of
more caravans and associated lighting
and noise from human activity
there would also be an adverse effect on
the setting of the nearby aonb as
expressed by the officer from the aonb
in his comments
i also refer to dm18 in brackets h on
tourism accommodation which only
supports such accommodation where it
protects and enhances the setting and
special qualities of the area of
outstanding natural beauty and provides
an overall environmental enhancement
when assessed throughout the year
i submit that no way does the proposed
development satisfy these policy
requirements
may i emphasize that the strategic and
other policies i've referred to and also
i should add st14 regarding the
enhancing environmental assets
were designed to protect what is left of
our precious green spaces and that the
lane and surrounding surrounding
countryside where the proposed site is
situated have particularly have become
particularly prone to detrimental
applications over the last 10 years or
so given this i hope you will vote to
retain the green nature of this precious
area
i should add that protecting our
unsupported countryside is vital if we
are to continue to attract tourists into
the area and to support our local
economy
i hope too that you've considered
concerns expressed about the likely
effect of the increased number of
caravans on the amenities of
neighbouring
properties i won't say any more on that
as mr hammond has already talked
extensively about that
i will do i also final paragraph
i also ask you to consider the effect on
the local highways um you may all be uh
familiar with long lane it is a very
narrow rural lane which goes between
apple door and westwood ho it is also
used by
walkers and horse riders and cyclists
the crossroads at broad lane
is also a very narrow area and
if there are more caravans coming down
there it is going to cause accidents
thank you very much for listening thank
you
our final contributor is board member
haynes
thank you sir
um yeah slightly at the risk of
repeating what the last speaker said
actually but um
anyway just to say don't reiterate and
emphasize that so although this uh
application reduces the number of
caravans nevertheless the same arguments
which were applied to the refusal of the
30 before should apply in my opinion to
this one
as the speaker said the site is in the
undeveloped coast and should be subject
to the governing policies um sd-21 st09
and
there are four tests which should be
applied to this application as it's been
said
and i should emphasize that the policy
says
not to detract from the unspoiled
character appearance and tranquility of
the undeveloped coast
and whether the development should go
else could go elsewhere
i submit the number of caravans applied
for would fail these tests the
characteristics surrounding countryside
appearance and tranquility would be
adversely impacted by the precedent
officially prominent white caravans and
associated lighting noise and smells
from human and pets animal activity
please note that you refused permission
from the previous application for 30
caravans because it would fail to
protect positive characteristics and
features of the coastal and estuary area
and i refer also to the applications for
a supervisory unit on the site which
have been refused by your council and at
appeal because of adverse impact on the
open countryside and what was in the
coastal preservation area
this development would have also had an
adverse impact on the setting of nearby
aonb um as expressed by the officer from
the aomd and his comments and also given
by this council is a reason for refusal
of the previous application
and i referred here to the policy dma
team concerning tourist accommodation
designed to protect and enhance the
setting and special qualities of the
aonb
and provide an environmental enhancement
when assessed throughout the year and i
submit that no way does the proposed
development satisfy this policy
there's also a policy norh regarding
prevention of coalescence between
settlements of northern and epidural if
allowed the development would
consolidate and increase the hamlet of
watertown and set a precedent for
further creeping development
may i emphasize the strategic and other
policies i've referred to
were designed to protect what is left of
our precious green spaces and that the
lane and surrounding countryside where
the proposed site is situated become
particularly prone to detrimental
applications over the last 10 years or
so
given this i firmly hope you'll retain
your vote to retain the green nature of
this precious area i should add that
protecting our own spiral countryside is
vital if we are to continue to attract
tourists to the area and support our
local economy
and our refer to policy st 13
on sustainable tourism which is designed
to protect our natural and historic
assets and forage in north devon
why therefore should we want to destroy
the unspoken coast which tourists come
here to see
i hope too you have considered strong
concerns expressed by the first speaker
about the likely
effect of the increased number of
current caravans or the amenities of
neighbouring properties
as you know the property is very close
to the site and this site is
particularly narrow the resident has
told you he already suffers from and has
complained about noise and disturbance
and this is likely to increase
unacceptably with 15 caravans
i refer to policy dmo one concerning
harm to amenities of neighbours and also
note that palmetto neighbors due to the
proximity of caravans that have
developed to their dwellings was another
reason given by this council for refusal
of the previous application
despite assurances of the applicants so
there will be noise and cooking smells
although there won't be noise and
cooking smells throughout the day and
night
these and lighting from the caravans
will severely impact labour's well-being
and this this disturbance will occur
right through the year
given these impacts and i suggest that
it is not really normal or acceptable
for approved caravan sites to be
situated so close to people's houses
certainly this is not my experience as a
caravan owner visiting sites in the west
country and i wonder if certain
councils on this planning committee
would agree with me within their
experience
i asked you to consider too the effect
on the local highways with an increase
in the number of caravans visiting the
site
as you know from your side visit the
lane at lanes accessing the site are
narrow and the junction of broad lane
with long lane is hazardous with
visibility non-existent imagine
therefore a large caravan that has been
negotiated negotiated around that
junction
surely an accident waiting to happen and
it's significant that a restriction is
currently in place at that junction
regarding lorries servicing a housing
development at the edge of west africa
i also refer to the likely effect on the
grade two listed oyster cottage for
junction a property which has been
damaged over the years by the increasing
volume of large vehicles negotiating the
tight corners also creating vibration
also a likely adverse effect on
pedestrians and cyclists on these lanes
local people will tell you that the
lanes which lack footprints are well
used every day by both categories to
walk and cycle to the burroughs and to
apple door in northern this fact makes
me amazed that the highways office
changed his mind from expressing concern
about the traffic hazard from the
caravan site when the last application
is discussed to consider
considering the situation acceptable
with a current application
i should point out that the caravan
traffic will be likely to occur daily
and the associated car journeys in and
out of the site will be made throughout
the day when visitors explore the area
or go shopping
in conclusion therefore i urge you to
refuse this application for the
environmental community and highways
recents i've given
thank you
thank you council haynes
that's the final speaker for this
application
so
we're going to open the
debate on this one
well
cancer councilman
thank you mr
is there any stipulation you've put in
for that acoustic barriers to be in
place
um and obviously you know
one trying to minimize the noise
if that gets run through i'm not saying
this isn't good for a bit but did go
through just question i'd like to
advance if you could answer uh obviously
for acoustic reasons and also visual as
well
thank you uh
no there is no proposal for a um
barrier um i don't think a condition
requiring one would be necessary
considering
the environmental protection officer is
saying effectively there's no objection
to the scheme uh regarding
nuisance and amenities so whilst i have
some advice with the
neighbours and it's not something i
would consider that i can secure or
would meet six tests um there is
there are existing uh hookups on that
belong that boundary was disputed
where their exact location is at this
moment time we have no um early come
back in a second
we have no um
control over where those carats can park
it's just an open field and that people
can come and park on where they are
really um the idea behind the screening
which you'll see on the side of facial
plan is to move caravans away from
potentially parking next to the craft
etc screening is not there it's a visual
break it's there as a to make sure that
karen's not parked up against my country
um at the most sensitive areas um
i hope you asked a question but i'm more
than happy to take
but can we go back to slide is what we
actually see from the the boundary
coming along the line
you know i think it's very important
about you know what i'm saying about
acoustic barriers or maybe some visual
swings going in there just on one side
probably i'm not getting the feels at
the moment is in use for a caravan site
very minimal use for it at the moment so
you know the practicality is already
there but
are we taking into consideration that
baby immunities for the neighbors we're
looking down as hedgerow now can we zoom
in
so you're talking about three hookups
going in that far end of the site the
far right-hand side of the site yeah i'm
not going to get north south east west
and as we look down there
as we see their name there's not much
barrier there at all is there
[Music]
i'm just going to say you know
if the application went through
and then we get enforcement coming in
left right and center because obviously
i understand the residents will complain
because it's going to happen
we're quite aware of that by the
speakers at the moment
yeah i'm just trying to
take devil's advocate at a moment you
know before i'm not going to sound for
or against that moment
unless i can be
kind of swayed into it when i first came
into that i was more in the line of
being forward a foreign application
if we can try and minimize harm to the
immunities
and residents locally but i don't think
we're doing that at the moment
and i'm not going to dig it i just it's
you know basically a conversation going
on here and any any good issues we can
put in
yeah i appreciate what you're saying um
in my opinion
that isn't necessary for the application
to be
approved
you could potentially condition it but
again i would question really whether
it's necessary which is one of the six
tests in the national council framework
which all conditions have to be
necessary and reasonable so
considering there aren't any objections
from our environmental protection team
regarding laws of nuisance
considering their existing cameras on
site five in the park up there uh today
tomorrow
anyway there's then there's from my
point of view
it's okay but you may just disagree and
agree to history that's um
[Music]
who is against his application measure
um
the measurements
from the hookups et cetera now can we
answer this please you know this right
personality are we correct
are we not correct and is that gentleman
correct and can we prove what the
measurements are which would then
in in my mind then i can actually
visualize where these pictures are
actually going on the site the these the
green pictures not this is left outside
i have no issues with the pictures
that's my size space on the right hand
side
okay so it's um if we can go back to the
photo so this is the only evidence
i have not been decided to take measure
and measured where these
are
the
as i've said the
existing caravans can park wherever they
like so there's i have no control on
where pictures are at the moment this is
a certified site for five paragraphs
they can park wherever they like
the idea behind the landscaping scheme
is to move the caravans away from the
crop
if you go to the site application
planters
so
they are now pushed
north as far as recently possible which
is away from
the actual best central dwelling the
conservatory the windows as far as
i confused the victim
i would say because their grass pitches
and this is why the landscaping support
we have no control over the way they
park
and that's why we have to secure this
basket buffer
because
really all we're considering
is the 10 pitches
that are
are there
we can then control where people find
people
park anyway really
um but it would make sense that apart
from the formalized ten pitches and then
the other five caravans in theory
like they do now
the point is that they're screaming
there and the buffer
which is achieved by planting
chris can i just ask you on that reading
that there talks about on an earth bank
is that about to be constructed or is it
the existing bank it was my
understanding there would be an
additional bank
well it would make sure that it is and
then to answer councillor mcgovern these
sites
[Music]
those locations and not anywhere else
and there's also
further screening we have
trees with old silver birch bonded crab
on the right hand side as you look at
that plan
to again screen so the sights for the
motorhomes or caravans will be as shown
on the planet and nowhere else on the
side yeah
that's
[Music]
so this is for the um it could be 15
sites and that to include the existing
five yeah but if they're supposed to be
on all hard standing
pitches how can you say that you've got
no control over where that being because
they've got to go out on saturday pitch
that's currently
yeah
you can't the five as chris said
the five
that are allowed now can park anywhere
in there
but once this if this is improvement
they'll have to park where it should be
yeah
so they
will strictly be able to move away from
the cross boundaries if the hard
standing pitches are on the other side
of the stomach
yes so the the idea is there's a
significant amount of planting in front
of the craft and to some extent see a
little bit clearly not as much um which
will prevent you can't
really from this reason so there'll be
parking will have to go either north or
south of any planting and then you have
the ten
harder sounding pitches on the other
side
um
can i just also add it it's really
really difficult
for our environmental protection team
[Music]
proximity to neighbours i'm not entirely
sure i agree with that and there's
there's no evidence to suggest that this
will cause nuisance um we can
investigate the nuisance respectively if
there is nuisance being uh
which arises
our
management protection team can
investigate that and they have their own
powers it would be absolute running on
the site okay to make sure that people
on it um
yeah just for another point several of
the speakers i listen to intently they
all
um mention the aonb comments but they
don't mention that the fifth paragraph
of their comment is the proposal has the
potential to reduce the undeveloped
green space on the edge of the
designated area but they also recognize
the important role of tourism and they
do not recommend outright reviews of
this application
so i think you've got to bear that in
mind as well
i think councilman locke has just hit
the nail on the henry this is about
balance isn't it
um
i have to say that over the weekend i
was in the south dawson um
if you've been there you will see what
blight on the landscape caravans are
they are very intrusive
because they have always white or pastel
colour and they're really doing true um
so i'm not a great fan of caravans but
putting that aside and
i was i was interested when i got the
agenda
there is a whole page of points from
northern town council i've never seen
quite so many actually
when we visited i think when councilman
bushby applied to this site
sorry i've just checked you the
applicant back in 2017. sorry
[Music]
this site before and there was an
application the thing that really struck
me
was the access
and i did hear one of the um objectives
to point out how difficult the access is
and there are no footpaths and this came
out very
it was actually stressed that the last
time we had this that if you park there
how do you get to anywhere because there
are no footpaths here and i'm surprised
it just doesn't seem to be
here now there's going to be more
caravans it'll be more people
um i heard about the impact on the
neighbours
obviously we all sympathize about that
um
personally i would have built the craft
but i'm sorry about that
because i think that's intrusive
but when i go down here and i go down
quite a lot
the thing is when you turn off here um
and you actually you go into the air b
you are suddenly trying to support it
into what is quite a wild area actually
and i've been going there for what 45
years now i used to take my students
down there and i'm very interested in
the whole geography of it
and
i'm afraid sticking caravans into it
doesn't really sit well with me
and the other thing the main point why i
have real reservations about this is
that our policy about the undeveloped
coast
it keeps coming up and yet we keep
seeing to find ways around it
and it's either a policy or it isn't
and we've had houses in the undeveloped
codes we had nap house we had all that
and
i think no i'm sorry but uh having more
caravans here really will impact on the
neighbours and i
i have real problems with it it isn't
a balanced item council locks it but i
listen to the other council that you use
before i met my wife
thank you counselor
can we go back to the original slide
that's the
first time
yeah this one here and i think we'll all
agree that the the current advocates
have done
all they can to
mitigate the the impact on crofty the
existing five
um green
um
the three that are uh the closest to the
craft are right down up against the
actual the boundary obviously there is
that page um
attempt to screen it i mean they can't
go any further than where they've gone
there
and i'm just trying to make the point
the once most of the the the owners of
the cross have quite legitimately put an
objection in the the owners of sea have
been on the one next door um
particularly see see haven which is the
closest one and the other places under
the entrance
they don't seem to have any problem with
it um
at all
um
i would just you know point out that
in our in our local plan you know we we
do aim to support rural tourism
and this you know this is rural tourism
and it's you know we're either going to
support rural
tourism or not
um much has been
made about the
highways aspect well highways don't have
any issues with it once they added some
original concerns those concerns have
been um
being addressed
footpaths there are no footpaths
anywhere along that road you know from
from the beginning of toronto all the
way
basically up to up to north or certainly
towards uh
um
i agree there are a lot of walkers there
but i don't see that this application is
necessarily going to increase that
dramatically and you only have to go a
short way to to
get to
the entrance to north america
i'm sure a lot of people will be heading
that way
but um
you know as i say it's in our local plan
we should be supporting rural tourism
[Music]
council mccree
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
i can confirm that it does appear to be
just a um
container it's a dark green color
um
i'm not certain
enforcement
[Music]
so
15 caravans so um what you said about
moving them over to
the west
they will still meet and try on the on
the right hand side of the plan
and
i would like to suggest that we move to
reject it
[Music]
thank you councillor craig
and check
can i speak
i like you speak cancer
yeah i mean i'd just like to sum this up
a little bit because we seem to be going
over and over and over with things
i've made some notes here
new planting for a start is going to
scream
the cross
highways have got no objection
and it's going to be for adults only
no caravans from november to march
which is a good thing in my opinion
no lighting on the site
environmental protection officer who's
got no objections
uh and at the moment
caravans can go on then just park
anywhere wherever they want and and that
this application will stop that so i
would
personally i would
like to
propose that we accept this application
but well i'll say i'll say that
because
i'm quite
surprised to hear really on the speakers
appledore have been complaining and
complaining about motorhomes parking on
the large car park down there and
parking in the streets
and with nowhere nowhere in the area for
motorhomes to park off-road nowhere
there's no site available
and
with all what's proposed on this that i
might put and i think i will propose a
10th
condition which is that all hookups and
water standpipes be located as shown on
that planet
so if they're not exactly where they're
currently where the front of the
speakers mentioned you know any
awareness shown on that plan so that
would make them have to be at that top
end of the site and at the other but
so i'll leave you to word that has
however shocked you
but with that
[Music]
but really
we really have to be providing something
for tourism in the area and
i go down broadly and council chris said
he goes down regularly i could i was
down this morning so i'm on the site
well and the road's quite wide as you
come down the road lane turn left to get
into here
it's further out by the world knows and
people walk and ride horses
every day and all day long there you can
walk into apple from there no problem
so
i think it's going to be a huge benefit
to the area and with the planting scheme
let's propose providing that is
constructed as shown in that plan
and the trees are put there as shown
i don't think to be honest
with anything to worry about and as
councilor watson mentioned it's for
people 25 and over so you know children
running about on the side kicking
footballs you know
and it will not be once
it will not be used
um
through the winter months so i'm going
[Music]
i know the answer is going to be no but
i'm going to ask it
um captain mentioned about the
non-cladding of these stories
which i was disappointed in that that
would be done
could that be
conditioned to this
i know i know it's nothing
but
it could be conditioner
sure
what i would suggest is that we raise
that as an enforcement matter um
to investigate because there is
conditional previous consent relating to
that oh yeah yeah thank you for that
i mean i do agree with councilman craig
that conditions we put on any planning
application are important now
right okay everybody thanks for that
it's been moved
by councillor watson certainly by me
that we approve this application could
you take the vote please
thank you chair
[Music]
and conditions are placed on fourth
council of watson four councillor
wiseman
that's seven four and two against chair
thank you
[Music]
c
[Music]
councilman morgan is an application
backer and he's going to speak as a
member of the public which is intact
and then they leave the room while we
discuss this
this application is on pages
68 to 7700
[Music]
so this application is for a covered
slurry store um it's come before
committee because it's councillor's
application
all details are in the coursework
so the location is um
just outside of bradwell
120 hectares of land in total
this is the main farm so
the site plan shows the sighting
of the slurry stool which is north
to the north of the main farm building
it is
measures about 45 meters in length
[Music]
so if you go to the next slide it shows
the section
so
half of it is on the ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next slide please
uh that's looking west uh at the
location so if you just see some times
on the ground marked out where where
it's going
um it will go
further to the left of that photo as
well and that's
north west so it sort of dips down into
a valley and there's other farms on the
other side
so next slide please
so that's another farm
similar buildings
uh
you can just see bradwell church in the
distance
[Music]
looking east
[Music]
so the main considerations are the
principal character by race research
towards quality so uh the principal
is obviously supported it's countryside
use uh the local plan is very supportive
of the world enterprise
um
under dm14
policy
so
that's accepted the character appearance
it is quite a large building
um
but the totally is allowed about
actually
half of it be underground
um
that as a building that you would find
in the countryside
it's not a dedicated landscape area
and it's pretty much close to the main
chart so
it would be led
buildings with the other buildings
um highways is no change to the access
residential immunity
it's about 150 meters from the nearest
um third-party dwelling
and there's no objections from
environmental protection
uh the air quality side things they
because it is above 500 square meters it
triggers the need for
a scale settlement
it's also
within proximity to si
so um a scale assessment was submitted
um
natural england was consulted on this
and they concluded that there's no
adverse impacts and have no objections
so that's
required in our air quality sbd
in terms of ecology
the covering of this
slurry tank is slightly to improve water
quality and
reduce runoff as required by
the environment agency
and yeah that goes into surface water
water quality
as well it doesn't actually trigger the
need for an ecology survey anyway but i
think given that the scale assessment
naturally
consulted
one agency
cleared it as well so um my
recommendation
for the amount of reasons would be to
improve
the application
thank you
thank you
we won speaker to this application which
is
richard balton who's the applicant
she'd like to just put the microphone
over on the table there kevin
[Music]
thank you
good morning the only reason actually i
speak because i just want to be helpful
from a farmer point of view just to give
a bit more
general information because
um these russian applications don't
often come for plans and just to give a
bit more information really
um so our current store would have been
put into the 1960s it's one of these
sort of tin tanks that you see quite a
lot around
um probably in the time since then we've
probably got four times without cows
we've had at that time
um because everybody's had to expand in
order to stay in business
um
anyway i've been away for some time that
that's hardly adequate really for our
needs and it all came to a bit of a head
last summer when
there was some rust hole started
developing it
and we were advised that really it was
beyond repair we didn't really ought to
sort of
put much in it at all
so i have to confess my first thought
was was to get on and do something and
then don't worry about applying later
but then on the flex and i thought
whatever idea
and
so
so what i then did
exactly and what i then did is i i
contacted the rpa
they were very pleased that i was taking
a proactive approach because i was
pretty worried as to what we were going
to do really
um because the only option is to sort of
continually spread as often as we could
through the winter which
whilst it is permissible because we're
not in an energy said fortunately um is
far from ideal so i said to them hey
chapel i'm going to spend a winter night
right he said well i'm afraid you will
yes
um so anyway we got on and got applied
family mission um which was going to
take some time um
one of the issues was because we're
close to bradley moore
and we had to have a stealth test that
was to just to check up on emissions
and unfortunately that's all fine
um
the
the reason it's so large
is because we
need to put in a store that will cover
for six months
and you know rosemary will tell you that
if you've got 200 more cows that's a lot
of slurry
um
so the reason it's being covered um is
partly to reduce ammonia emissions but
also
that avoids reduces and obviously if
you've got rainfall into it that's a lot
of water falling into it which is a lot
more volume stuff to shift
so by covering it um that obviously is
going to be beneficial
um
the other benefit that we found is that
if you can spread slurry in the
summertime rather than winter
it is hugely beneficial to the soil
um
we've also we've invested in a dribble
bar which means that you can just drop
the slurry onto the
grass rather than spray it
and so
that reduces smells which obviously
makes us popular with our neighbours but
if you can smell it then also what that
means is all the goodness is going off
into the atmosphere rather than into the
ground
so that is to some extent we win really
so what i'm hoping is is that we will
considerably save on fertilizer costs
and also obviously help the environment
as well
um
i could probably talk carol waxing
lyrics about slurry all day but i think
that's probably
[Music]
yeah you'll have to leave your room
while we've
had a long debate
[Music]
they
[Music]
[Music]
application
um the environmental protection agency
have got more and more inspectors going
out onto farms
and there's more and more tight rules
and regulations as to when and how and
how much sorry you can spread the cost
of fertilizer is absolutely quadrupling
price and i think counts about and
um
news stories all be absolutely
beneficial both to himself and the
environment so i would recommend a
second batch
that sent me back so approved uh
recommended for approval by council
unlock
seconded by councillor watson
and
the speaker there was uh gave me a lot
of information about slurry
and i didn't know before so
perhaps i'd have to meet up with the
counselor again i'm attracted with the
slurry yeah
many times it's been it's been moved to
approve nobody else wants to comment on
this
it's been moved for approval by
councillor lock sitting back as the
watsons
[Music]
thank you chad councillor bushby or
chancellor christie or councillor
or
[Music]
unanimous chair thank you sandra
what time are the sandwiches coming
okay
[Music]